okay this you have to see
Donald Trump is really in trouble with
his own followers Donald Trump has made
two pro-vaccine public comments over the
last week or 10 days and he is in so
much trouble with his own followers that
he had to go to Marjorie Taylor green to
try to clean it up let me remind you of
what took place first of all at the
Trump Bill O'Reilly event from last I
believe it was early last week or late
the previous week Donald Trump saying
the vaccine's good and I got the booster
and the crowd booing take a look but
look we did something that was historic
we saved tens of millions of lives
worldwide we together all of us not me
we we got a vaccine done three vaccines
done and tremendous Therapeutics like
regeneron and other things that have
saved a lot of lives
we got a vaccine done in less than nine
months it was supposed to take from 5 to
12 years because of that vaccine because
of that vaccine millions and millions of
people I think this would have been the
Spanish Flu of 1917 where up to a
hundred million people died this was
going to ravage the country far beyond
what it is right now
take credit for it take credit for it's
a great what we've done is historic
don't let them take away don't take it
away from ourselves you're playing that
you're playing right into their hands
when you sort of like oh the vaccine if
you don't want to take it you shouldn't
be forced to take it no mandates but
take credit because we saved tens of
millions of lives take credit don't let
them take that away from you okay so the
president made news you agree with that
right
both the president and I are vacs and uh
do you get the booster
yes I got it too okay so um
that's a very tiny group of it so that
was the first incident second incident
was Donald Trump interviewed by Candace
Owens Candace Owens wanting to do the
anti-vax stuff with Trump and Trump's
saying no the vaccines are good the
vaccines are an accomplishment and the
people that are getting sick and dying
are the people who are unvaccinated
remember that clip we see the corruption
right it doesn't seem like anybody ever
pays for the corruption and right now
we're seeing corruption live even in
terms of big Pharma which is a huge
topic on the minds of mothers especially
you're seeing what's happening at these
school board meetings where do you stand
on these vaccine mandates and obviously
I know that you are you are pro-vaccine
obviously did everything you could to
get this vaccine out I know it was one
of the greatest achievements we did one
in less than nine months to be able to
do that but where but now taking a Twist
right it's gotten now we went from this
is a good thing and people should have
this option to military men you're going
to have to resign because you're not
getting this vaccine where do you stand
on that well I stand on forget about the
mandates that people have to have their
freedom but at the same time the vaccine
is one of the greatest achievements of
mankind we would have had a 1917
remember the Spanish flu killed perhaps
100 million people actually it ended the
first world war because the soldiers was
a lot of people don't know that the
soldiers got so sick it was a terrible
thing there were no vaccines it would
know anything I came up with a vaccine
with three vaccines all are very very
good came up with three of them in less
than nine months it was supposed to take
five to 12 years and these people have
died under covet this year by the way
under Joe Biden then under you and more
people took the vaccine this year so
people are questioning how oh no the
vaccine worked but some people aren't
they the ones the ones that get very
sick and go to the hospital are the ones
that don't take their vaccine but it's
still their choice and if you take the
vaccine you're protected look the
results of the vaccine are very good and
if you do get it it's a very minor form
people aren't dying when they take the
vaccine how about the masking of
children this has thrown the Trump World
into a tailspin we talked about it
yesterday so many Trump followers
believe that they have been
um uh backstabbed for lack of a better
term by Donald Trump and so Donald Trump
now trying to clean it up through
Marjorie Taylor green and Marjorie
Taylor green is sort of the perfect
person to do it as an anti-vaxx
Republican she put together this big
Twitter thread where she says I just got
off the phone with Trump
we talked about vaccines and mandates we
talked about covid and how the virus
from China has been politicized she says
I have President Trump's permission to
tell you all he is 100 against the
mandates but he encourages everyone to
get the vaccine he also said if he was
President he would never mandate
vaccines and no one would be fired the
key thing to remember is where covid
came from China we should be holding
those who made the virus accountable
made the virus made the virus a very
dubious term given what we know about it
and protecting our freedoms while
promoting life-saving treatments and
giving the vaccines to those who want it
not forced not forced for everyone that
criticizes Trump about when covid
started with Shoulda Coulda wouldas I
think he administration did the best
they could
the virus was brand new we'd never seen
anything like it Biden deserves the
criticism and then they just move on to
other apologia Trump says you wouldn't
be paying these gas prices if he was in
charge Keystone would be under for uh
under construction Biden is a disgrace
on and on going on to talk about Iran
and other things
um this is actual sort of Crisis
management done in a really really
strange way Trump said something for
once that's true and for once that's
uncontroversial the people
disproportionately dying from covet or
the people without a vaccine even in the
context of Omicron as we talked about
earlier and Trump's audience is so
weaponized against him that they went
nuts and now he's going to Marjorie
Taylor green to try to help him clean it
up let's hope that this is Trump's
undoing Trump finally telling the truth
about something maybe his undoing with
his own followers the monster he created
is completely out of control and has
turned against him and it is delightful
to see
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee for sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee with both lion's
mane and chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms
have actually been shown to have
potential in supporting the immune
system in peer-reviewed studies I've
been drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any delicious coffee but it's
really easy on my stomach doesn't give
me any jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over twenty thousand five
star reviews and best of all if you
don't love it you'll get 100 of your
money back because they stand behind
their product you've got nothing to lose
by giving it a try four sigmatic is
giving my audience up to 40 percent off
and free shipping when you go to four
sigmatic.com
the link is right underneath this video